literally rooting for a snow day was
like the most important thing in my life
at one point like like when a key
weather was wrong and I had to go to
school when they promised me nine inches
and I was gonna be out was devastated
we can't
[Music]
hi Karen family see you quickly thing I
love this office thank you brother
why it's my light not work it oh I saw
something what's that oh [ __ ] I want
green tea sir you love that yeah I love
that but that makes me upset
well it's only in the lead don't you see
it's in the lead
Coffee water to your skirts oh cool hi
guys doing what's that just the Green
Team would be amazing thank you bro I'm
super ChaCha get out like I love ya how
old are you 30
yeah it all comes down like it's just
the [ __ ] that like you got excited about
like that brings back memories
right it's why people get pumped when
they see you right they think about a
time yeah right that's what it is right
it's and by the way think about what
that time usually means to somebody
simple as [ __ ] like the shipping you
thought was terribly important is like
you wish could be your headaches now
[Music]
this guy named Bob Kerr Bob Carr who
created the monorail for Disneyland he
designed all these an engineer yes the
original Imagineers for just call so
he's 87 years old he's got all these
crazy stories but he was explaining you
know we were we were talking and we kind
of landed on that of like why is it
different for when a fan comes up to us
as opposed to like oh yeah you're on
that very Kent show on that one it's the
moment in their lives because the first
time they rode the front of the monorail
and they were eight years old they had
that memory for the rest of their lives
so when they see Bob they're like they
tie him to that memory you know that
simple time of when it was just like a
cookie and 100% so it's even like it's
even like ass like there's certain songs
that I hear that I like like cuz I know
like they were like songs like when I
like the girl or I think you know
like or smells like well smells really
tricky because people manipulate it
pretty hard like department stores and
like casinos and like like that's where
they really get you you know
[Music]
cinnamons like the big one like cinnamon
cookies like is a big five right see
Damon no you know perfect please
disregard keep them five years old right
so you have no [ __ ] say you didn't
have love yet your parents wanted you to
act or you you wanted act it was it was
a combination late morning like hey you
want to act you're like yeah I mean
you're five yeah it was more of I was
obsessed with like old classics oh so
you were into it and where were you
living that's why I love all this kind
of stuff like I grew up if you come by
my house my house looks like Disneyland
you know I mean there's just stuff all
over the walls and memorabilia and toys
and it's very colorful and you know I
grew up on Martin and Lewis and Abbott
Costello and all these great comedy
teams and the Marx Brothers and all that
Elvis and so at a young age my dad would
just see me kind of trying to do [ __ ]
sound like Jerry Lewis and follow you
know do so he's like you know he
originally he loves baseball you know so
he's like putting me a little league
team right of stuff and I'm like yeah I
like playing baseball if you're like
doing who's on first yes with that
[Laughter]
that's what keep your on the [ __ ]
ball and then he realized he's like man
my good for your dad that's a good job I
hope he's not Jersey right like in
Jersey where was the last cal in Cali
God we're now well I was in Orange
County at the time so yeah so he just
figured do my kid doesn't wanna play
baseball he wants to be doing something
that's in entertainment and so we didn't
have any idea we had no background we
didn't know what we were doing and then
he I think he just kind of opened up
yeah
Oh see weekly it was like Oh Alan Asian
you know like the old movie you have and
we come in and it's like yeah I got all
the kids likes lined up they're like
next you know and and that was just kind
of that's cool then I started doing
commercials and all that and then did
you freak when you first when you first
saw yourself on a commercial yes it was
like crazy you know I had a kid I went
to high school with that was the face of
Nintendo cereal I hope it's a bit we
still think it's the best thing it was
like the best like it's always like
literally first thing a high schoolers
like kid who's into that big name a
candy you know you read it yeah you
dominated commercials yeah the most
left-field
I know things like something that was so
whacked out left field but I mean I did
the clap like I you know the taste you
can see like all the the the classic
ones that you remember you know I've
done the cinnamon toast crying oh gosh
there's the you know do you remember the
guessers commercial yes yeah that you
were danced by
yeah your commercials used to run
against your own show so it'd be like me
playing game boy and then the next thing
would be like me like talking about but
yeah so anyway how long how long did
that show run but when I kind of like
changed a great job we did well that's
an interesting that's interesting
we did four seasons but we only did 56
episodes and it sort of just kind of
became the honeymooners how the
honeymooners did like 33 episodes and it
just it's not more the honeymooners did
isn't that crazy
that's insane that's and that's what
people say when I say drinking Johnny
because people imagine you're like blown
away right now yeah they're blown away
gear up people people think the dream I
think Saved by the Bell feels like that
to me and say by the Bell was sure yeah
I was only like 80 episodes yeah because
I feel like I know them all I was cuz we
went to save by the max the other day I
was just gonna and so I was getting
interested in like you know yep yeah
rewatching the seasons and everyone's
going to that say by the max right yeah
I know the culture is only one teaser
I'm so obsessed with Kelly Kapowski oh
my god
so obsessed with her yes so you did that
for years and then what happened and for
some reason it just like and then what
happened you might fall did you start
getting into into music oh no yes I
played started playing music a lot well
I started doing music early like about
10
while you're in a little while yes so
I've always had a passion for music
started playing drums and I was like
little kid yeah and then yeah exactly
and then didn't want to be in the back
of the band didn't I I wanted to write
songs I couldn't write on drums like I
had to find other musicians if I wanted
to play music you know so I I was like
screw that I'm gonna play guitar and I
had to learn
fortunately the movie with Roger Daltrey
and Danny Lane and come on a piece and
all these like rock legends and they
really put you on learn how to play
guitar for the movie gave me I had to be
able to play guitar so they gave me this
amazing guitar coach and so just like
standard impetus is like happen like oh
here you wanted to play guitar here's
here here you can hang out with Roger
Daltrey refer to me for two months and
learn everything about being on the road
with the WHO and stupid crazy stories of
Keith Moon and he'd come in the student
you know pick up the guitar and show me
stuff and he was really really rad and
then I got to actually go in the studio
and record with him because we were
doing songs for the movie so at the very
beginning of me starting to play guitar
I'm already I'm already like a merciless
crazy so cool yeah and then started
writing songs and putting a little bands
together nothing like that and then I
booked a show called The Amanda Show
which was basically The Carol Burnett
Show for kids and that was Amanda Bynes
for me I remember all that is not a joke
this is not a joke I've seen most of the
Amanda Bynes movies I genuinely
genuinely like like 8 to 15 year old
girl movies I mean like like it was
great yeah the one where she was like
like the soccer girl she's the man is a
[ __ ] I'm gonna you know what I'm
tweeting that right now she's the man
there's an all-time classic movie I'm
excited to see what's about to happen
I'm about to lose so many followers
you're gonna notice it's gonna be the
opposite again you're gonna get the
Olsen twins they're so good we find her
love you John that movie I [ __ ] love
it
yeah they're also very good
yeah but amanda bynes I mean she you
loved her yeah yeah I mean she was
amazing so we booked I got onto that
show which is sketch comedy which I
loved it was like completely my was what
I grew up on I wanted to be you know
Jerry Lewis doing sketches and go Stefan
you always want to be an SNL yeah
exactly
so I got to do that yeah so I got to do
that and then at the same time I was
making music and the second season of
the manna show they brought on an actor
named Josh Peck was this really funny
amazing kid and we were I was already a
staple on the show and he was sort of
the new comer and so he would all about
Amanda and I would do stuff together and
they would be the kid that comes in and
asks for something we make everything
funny yeah mm-hmm but we started to
really gel and just something they
started to see off-camera and these
things happen so they started putting up
some sketches more together where we
worked off each other and we were more
becoming like the Tim Conway Harvey Show
and becoming sort of a Abbott Costello
and and so they spun us off from that
show garyun Josh that's how it happened
yeah and so we got we we were just yeah
it's fun off onto that and then the the
music on the show way I was able to
incorporate all my own music was the Dan
Schneider the executive reduce it was
just a big fan of the music and he'd
heard it on the Amanda show and all
during while we're shooting that
and he was like do you want to do you
want to have a play music to hide your
character to have music incorporated you
want to keep that separate what do you
want to do and I'm like no I mean any
time I like
guitar player yeah yeah you know a rock
and roll yeah I want something like good
music and yeah let's do it's incorporate
to music this is actually a cool story
so I I I get that phone call on a Friday
and he goes okay think about it over the
weekend I want to meet with you on
Monday we're gonna talk about how
whether or not you even want to
incorporate your music and if you do how
much do you want to you want to have
your own music do you want us to write
songs for the character like how do we
want to approach this so I said okay
cool so that day I called my and Moses
is I'm probably like 15 at this point
yeah I'm like 15 at this point and so I
called my buddy and I go hey man I have
this meeting on Monday about the music
and this is why I write music with I'm
like let's get together and try and
write a theme song for the show that's
cool you know and I'm like thinking yeah
right like we'll ever get it but let's
just why not so it'd be good to show
here Rita and I got a great relationship
with dance so I have no fear of him
going it's [ __ ] or it's great uh yeah I
don't have any fear of him saying that
I'll be like okay cool let's go get
lunch
you know so we went I went on that
Saturday I went in and we were trying to
think of all the themed days go by and
you know different since you've been
theme songs and nothing was coming and
we were just sitting there and it was
just like just brain-dead for 12 hours
you know so I said you know screw this
let's just try and write a song so we
don't waste the day so let me start
writing a song and it's a pretty cool
song kind of Elvis Costello vibe rock
and roll vibe and all my calluses cool
that's like wait a minute what is the
themes don't even sound like what would
you try to sound like a theme song let's
just write a good song and make the
lyrics sort of go along with with themes
of the trace themes of the show which is
basically these two guys who are
complete polar opposites
their parents get married and now they
have to live together in the same room
and they hate each other but at the end
of the day
you know but at the end of the day they
need each other they love each other its
bosom buddies or it's perfect strangers
perpetrators was the best exactly so
that's the chemistry so let's just write
a song about that you know and it became
I never thought it'd be so simple but I
found the way I found a way if you open
up your mind it's gonna take some time
you know over your shoulder always be
picking you up when you're down so it's
like this very friend like hey I got
your brother and we recorded a little 1
minute demo I went to Dan on Monday and
I'm you know Sam just had boombox
anywhere and actually funny talking
about Amanda Bynes he was working on
what I like about you at the time
Amanda's show so I was over the WB lot
you're on her stage and we found a
little boombox on in the prop Department
and plugged it in and he's like man I
just listened to it without you here I I
don't know if I what am I supposed to
tap my foot now yeah sure sure this is
awkward
if you don't like it you don't like it
we like like the same kind of music
learning you know like I trust your
opinion if you don't like it then you go
with whatever else and then doesn't ruin
my day doesn't you know whatever so he's
like all right so he presses play and
the one minute little demo version of
found away goes by and he just stands up
unplugged it and walks out of the room
and starts walking over go straight guys
see what everybody wanted to everyone
that's working on the stage goes when
you hear the theme song my new show and
he plugs it in onstage and starts
playing it to everybody at home I was
sick and then and he just looks at me
he's like alright well I just have to
convince Nickelodeon but that's that's
our theme song that what to call found a
way all right yeah that's what names on
and so I of course you know
fifteen-year-old me I'm like what them
are you kidding me like I was expecting
type of foot snap a finger hey kid get
out of here and it just so cool turned
out yeah I got to call my buddy and I
was like yo bro we just got a theme song
like we booked it like and then it was a
smash hit show yeah and then the
Showtime up and now it's crazy I do it
I go to countries all over the world
where they don't even speak the language
you know and they think missus how can
you start off with well
oh no it's just that some clones are out
everyone knows every lyric to it and
it's like we were talking about earlier
it brings them back in that moment like
you were saying the son sitting on the
couch simple day yeah it's like all
you're worried about was like it's a
hoping first snow day
literally literally literally rooting
for a snow day was like the most
important thing in my life at one point
you look like when a key weather was
wrong and I had to go to school when
they promised me nine inches and I was
gonna be out was devastated you didn't
have that new safe dude honestly yes sir
yeah you warm weather kids you [ __ ]
missed out there's nothing like having a
test that you're not prepared for it
gets snowed out okay okay yeah but the
problem with that is like people are
dead and [ __ ] like you can't be like
yeah I'm it's like with me it was like I
miss science cuz it's no you're like I
miss science 83 are dead all I got is oh
it's sprinkling we're gonna watch a
movie in the auditorium today like that
right rain really [ __ ] with you guys
like rain [ __ ] with LA that's it yeah
but sprinkles you can't drive it new on
iridescent Florida and it's torrential
downpours and everyone's just like yeah
yeah yes I think but yes any of that
right yeah into the president now has
cutting records and jewelry and Incan
focusing on music I've made a couple
movies last year that came out this year
but just like you feel yourself so thin
it's like you feel like you're
gravitating more and more every day to
music yeah and you can only get so the
other thing with the other thing with
when I think about music and acting is
there's something very evergreen about
acting like if I'm you knowing your
narrative like especially with having
the win under your belt of acting like
you can act in 40 years like if you know
like it feels like musics like to me it
would be harder pressed for me to
believe in 40 years you make that album
yeah or that song maybe possible
it just feels more practical to me Harry
plus you always care about the thing you
don't have like if you're to hit you
know it's the same old thing like
[ __ ] Justin Timberlake wants to win
an Academy Award like you know what I
mean like what you have you know it's
like the hole I talked a lot about
entrepreneurship nowadays and I'm alone
like man it's so crazy
athletes used to want to be rock stars
and rappers rappers and that rock charge
used to want to be athletes and now
everybody wants to be an entrepreneur
you just always want what you don't have
it's just human nature especially if you
care about multiple things it's like
like I love sports I gave up on the
Rangers and the Yankees the second they
won like it's all Knicks and jets now
it's not like they did anything other
than win a [ __ ] championship you know
it's just the way humans are wired
especially being competitive yeah how do
you categorize your music I can't wait
to go listen now are you sorry with
somebody knows myself love that and that
role okay what can I help with what are
we what when you were thinking about
this meeting yeah it's sort of just kind
of so basically how did we get here how
did we okay so and that's basically what
I was getting into here is there we have
more control now that the music like
you're you trying to get acting it's
like wait [ __ ] waiting around for
someone to hire you cookies no with the
music with the music we can take control
and release records when we want make
records when we want you know go to what
we want play where we want and not use
agents managers labels any of that and
just basically do it ourselves
so what kind of in that I'm basically in
that position where for the first time
you know I've been on labels I've been
signed I've released records every way
that you you can think of except now I'm
doing it by parental independent and I
control the Masters yeah and like have
all the upsides to be an entrepreneur
it's like in a sense I'm finding myself
like
whoa I went from being an artist on a
label to now I'm like running a business
okay you've got to like do the marketing
and distribution that I've got to think
about everything yeah do you like that
yeah yeah it's great that and I love
feels like you can die to know in sort
person I love it so I love being able to
I think I think I'm super like I think
marketing is so [ __ ] creative like
you know I think people don't think
about it the way they think about
painting or acting or music but like the
way I think about making people care
about something feels like super art and
that's I think what grab like what drew
me to you know I think I saw you with my
buddy T grizzly and then and then then I
sort of was like who is this guy what am
i what's going on here and then I just
started following you and started you
know you were just like everything you
were saying I'm like yeah that's right
yeah so you know about two years ago
maybe I had like this whole term where I
was like dude if I'm not getting up if
I'm not getting up before everybody else
is getting up if I'm not doing what
everybody else isn't doing if I'm not
gonna find then I'm just gonna be like
everybody else and everybody's sitting
there going oh I didn't know we're
getting like dude and then once you
start doing nature getting up buck
crack-of-dawn you you know 4:00 in the
morning going to gym go and doing this
and going to the gym again then going
working on everything you're doing like
just tryna kill it you know you start to
realize when everyone's like oh it
doesn't really seem like I'm sitting
here laughing because it's the biggest
single thing that affected them like you
thought you worked hard yeah that's the
thing I mean I see people on Instagram
and they're like this is what hard work
looks like and it's 11:30 and they look
like they just woke up and they're doing
something on the computer or something
or they're editing a video and you're
like you would dude you should be you
should its 11:30 you should be like
that's like dinnertime like you should
be already boom boom boom so anyway so I
don't want answers I gave up pretty
fresh and like why did I give that I'm
like looking at him like why do I give
those that
I'm reading the bill nice book right now
it says so funny book is like it's like
two years old and like yeah I think it's
a good 18 it's minimally 18 months old
yeah and like it's been brought up like
four times this week it's funny how
things are near got it so that's how
that's how at the radar and then more
importantly as you did your homework you
like wait a minute this guy really
understood the tender stands like the
marketing of getting people to pay
attention to you exactly yeah and so it
sort of seemed like wow I'm gonna be
somebody that I you know doing this on
our own you know and we crashed already
ready I mean it's really simple its
distribution like one [ __ ] that when
the Internet's young and there's 40
[ __ ] channels and you have a hit show
and Nickelodeon everybody knows who you
are
in today's world it's [ __ ] so
fragmented everything's fragmented so
it's about figuring out how to get your
music consumed at all costs now
SoundCloud and spotify are [ __ ]
incredible because that's the info
strata
that's the infrastructure of where
people naturally go i think the white
space is where people don't go i think
the white space is theme songs i think
like the white space is twitch stars
playing with your music in the
background like to me I just think that
wherever there's attention you need to
try to figure out how to get music I
think that somebody right now is running
marketing I think somebody right now is
running retail store operations at
Sephora who grew up as you being their
biggest crush because she's 29 and
thinks you're the [ __ ] coolest and if
you like figured out how to get to
Sephora
they would play your [ __ ] music in
every Sephora store 19 times a day on
loop and somebody's like what's that
hook like to me it's how do you
penetrate culture like how does your
hook play on mean pages on insta on
people's vlogs and you know how does
d-roc using the vlog that's exactly
right
but here's the thing I'm dying to know
how many people actually listen to it in
a world of an iPhone and all of us want
to listen to her
Sabra you know what I mean like I'm with
you and I'm not against it at all what
scares the [ __ ] out of me is 118 second
snippet in a [ __ ] Paul brother Lulu
Hogg one time is gonna get to a lot of
years yeah so to me
whether it's the theme songs of video
games while you're making your dynasty
team whether it's twitch players which I
think are absolutely gonna grow at
scales that were like especially you
know for pop audiences whether it's
Dylan's Candy Bar is playing it in the
stores whether it's you know it's just
[ __ ] full penetration cuz you're
always one you know what's amazing about
music it's kind of like making videos
you're one [ __ ] that bad away like it
blows my face off that you could write
and record 813 songs b67 record one
little [ __ ] thing randomly on some
stupid [ __ ] like you didn't give it
anywhere close to the thought you did
about 80 other percent of your songs and
that's the one yeah I always think that
we you know so a lot of people when they
watch this will say you always say the
same advice too when the rappers come
and hang out with you you're always
giving the same advice I'm like I'm like
yeah that's what I think is the right
thing like you know it's like a play in
sports like if they don't stop it keep
running it and then you win to me
it blows my mind that people were signed
to you know to [ __ ] Arista Records
and this has happened hundreds of times
what I'm about to tell you faked
scenario artist manager labels sitting
in a room 1987 17 songs for the album
and they decide to not use the
eighteenth song and use this other song
and that eighteenth song was the [ __ ]
song that has happened hundreds of times
the fact that you don't have to worry
about that and you can just do little
four pack music albums one offs [ __ ]
oh this is the greatest time ever to be
you to be an artist but the supply is
greater than ever
yes cutting through it sure
I honestly think that's merit cutting
through is predicated on are you good
right are you good at music you know
somebody tweeted just actually that's
[ __ ] crazy somebody just tweeted and
I saw and I got involved in tweet you
know this is [ __ ] [ __ ] social
media stars are getting more bigger
advances than people that have been
doing music all their lives is that what
it is that's probably why it happened
nonetheless audiences audience
yeah like ask me itani is [ __ ] at
like the amount of [ __ ] 13 to 22 year
old girls that are obsessed with him and
like through the roof they buy a [ __ ]
lot of music like if you're a label
you're like alright let me get this rate
like an enormous amount of 12 to 25 year
olds like think you're the best yeah
like like how do you think that's gonna
play out like you know it doesn't
translate until it does to your point
like airplanes a shitty movie like the
Kardashians is [ __ ] until it's not
yeah guys you're you're in the Hollywood
world I I went there a lot during this
time
Netflix got [ __ ] on by Holly lately [ __ ]
on I'd be at CAA like hearing people
like like I would bring it up and like I
really like what Netflix they like stuff
like like Netflix was like like made PBS
feel like HP out like like you know it
was like so you know that to me that's
what's great our guy T grizzly it's
great that if his song the four days
after jail is fire then his career
starts there's plenty people like so to
me the audience is the only one and all
of our [ __ ] opinions and [ __ ] all
the media outlets and all the managers
and all the agents and all the
publications and meme accounts it's just
the audience there's nothing else and to
me penetrating them
and giving yourself an at-bat and then
and then and then really trying to
figure out how to bring value to a the
audience always but you do that by
nature in trying to produce a piece of
art that people enjoy and then be trying
to find leverage with the distributor
you know whoever's distributing that
music you have the ultimate leverage for
a certain demo 27 to 30 six you'll faint
and good Fame nostalgic warm fuzzy beam
I just think a lot of people just say
yes I just if I were [ __ ] on this
team I'm just like sitting down with you
guys and like hung out for 60 days I'd
be like right I'll try to figure out who
we think watched Nickelodeon and is 26
to 34 years old let's go let's the show
to your point six year old 10 year olds
13 year old there's no demographic but
the twenty seven twenty eight year olds
will call up a radio service and now the
program directors and now that this and
that are oh of course we grew up on that
if you're what if your week if you're
waking up at dawn like I'll tell you
right now three to five at like the
first thing I would do is hire somebody
at minimum wage free or like a low
salary to literally business develop on
DM 24 hours a day
mmm-hmm and again if you're 28 year old
Sally or Rick and they think you're the
cool like I would have done it for bacio
man for free oh yeah you know like you
know like it's a trade yes d-roc did it
for a little because it was afraid he
thought I was cool laughter he did his
homework you know he thought it was
worthwhile and he was right like you
know so to me I actually just think it's
grinding I think the 2018 version of
going to show doing shows every night at
shitty [ __ ] restaurants and [ __ ]
pubs and [ __ ] this and that which you
probably would have not had to do to the
same shitty level given the prior equity
that you had but like if you're a
comedian today you can either go and do
open mic or you can make content and
then DM
people for those same four hours like I
don't I think people underestimate like
I don't think people have understood the
depth of spending four or five hours
trying to connect with people yeah and
bring them the problem is the people
that understand it are either the most
desperate or the smartest the most
desperate just spam you I don't know I
just get spammed [ __ ] fifty thousand
times a day the smartest win and then
everybody else just disregards it I just
don't think it's disregarding like he
beat me to like and you know he even
beat me to it it's like that's my
blocking us in yeah why yeah I love the
show we the same way if I apologize same
way when I see a Jets player like I can
be on se caen DME and if underneath that
is Tom Hennessy the long snapper the
Jets I'm like yo hit up Hennessy we'll
get to Beyonce in four minutes you know
like it's everybody has what they care
about I think you have you've been doing
that for collaboration and purposes I
think you'd have to start thinking about
that for distribution purposes yeah
we've definitely been using it for
collaboration just like makes sense
hustling I love that but I would say go
go look at all the pop pop culture music
pop eight 90s nostalgia like I would go
to every [ __ ] I would go to every
Nickelodeon mean page and DM be like
yeah it's me it would mean a lot to me
if you [ __ ] play this one-minute clip
of of my song you know what you should
look up tear a wack you see what's going
on with her she's really interesting
she's artists that we really kind of
like got into she just dropped a project
and it's going super viral her name is
tiara whack tea
or what she did was super smart she
dropped an album 15 songs all one-minute
songs so that the whole song would fit
into an interim video and then she's
gonna watch how everybody reacts and
make full versions of the songs that
really popped no way
clever that's very close so she did to
the crowd feedback and he's a real songs
like yeah yes and she's very Missy
Elliott like Lauren Hill she's like
she's a real talent yeah and by the way
it was like 420 thousand two minutes ago
like everybody's co-signing him cuz she
put out this I mean this is real music
yeah like if you go to Twitter if you go
to our Twitter everybody everybody's
like meek mill's like she's next like
she's really hit it what I think you
should consider is making one minute
videos that are collateral that you can
p.m. all these people they're always
looking for content it's it's a real
grind I don't think people realize how I
got here I [ __ ] spent 14 hours a day
on Twitter from 2007 to 2010 like every
day yeah everybody thinks it's overnight
just that's it it's like my daddy comes
my dad will come in to over to my house
and say well I don't like the guys over
here doesn't know guys I'm like dad you
don't understand like you don't just
create an app and then it just happens
on Thursday and then 35-minute links to
me years and years and years of research
and development also and by the way even
even when it happens overnight and
snapchat at a very fast path yeah
there's one of them yeah like you go win
the lotto - yes yeah let's go yeah go to
a million let's go [ __ ] America go
[ __ ] it yes scratch off your [ __ ] like
it doesn't work that way
yeah like 12 years
Beyonce [ __ ] shaked her ass from like
[ __ ] nine years old on Star Search to
this [ __ ] her dad was dragging those
[ __ ] four girls everywhere [ __ ]
rodeo that [ __ ] mall this like it
[ __ ] takes work to your point that
four and ten a.m. thing like it's work I
worked for fifteen hours a day
I [ __ ] was in Helsinki last week had a
full day in Helsinki [ __ ] flew to
America and [ __ ] started that day
like [ __ ] like you know and everyone's
like I was so lucky but you got to give
yourself a chance and I think one minute
music videos distributed even if it's
like I'll tell you something real clever
I even think one minute the like I would
be filming everything you and your
writing partner or somebody else like
like even just a snippet of like the
making of a song do you know I'm happy
you would be right now if you had the
film of the 12 hours where you made the
theme song oh yeah do you know how cool
this is gonna be when we watch this
exact video in 40 years yeah it's cool
so I would be recording more and I would
be thinking about Instagram is gonna
have another 24 to 36 months no matter
what happens anything could happen but
like there's so I mean like our
society's attention that we care about
lives there winning there matters period
and then you can listen if I'm a
songwriter then I'm gaming it itself you
know I was telling one really big
hip-hop artist I was like eat the day
Roseanne Barr thing I'm like you need to
go in studio and create a song called
bars with two hours thing you know and
just like [ __ ] talk about your point
of view on not necessarily ruin of
course you want to make one reference to
Roseanne but it's more about like social
commentating on the State of the Union
yeah you know when you're when you're a
[ __ ] when you're a [ __ ] songwriter
you got power like there's a [ __ ]
volcano autumn ala right now right like
you could write about it if it was
authentic
I saw cap gee must have some family
there or maybe as a families but like
you know he should be in studio right
now making a song or donating all the
proceeds to the victims of Guatemala and
like call it volcano and just go that
could be the biggest hit in all of South
America this whole summer you see where
I'm going we are the world I think a lot
of times in like we are the world you
know yeah
when Nicky Jim just did that thing with
Will Smith about World Cup
smart here comes the World Cup it's
[ __ ] too popular people a lot of
audience right of course of course and I
think they did it because they had a
deal already but like if they didn't
like you could just see commercials
heading them up hacking culture both
from a writing standpoint and a
distribution standpoint like I make
videos for 47 year olds and then run ads
on Facebook for better people who are 47
it's gonna be something I'm gonna say
something different than what's gonna
I'm not gonna talk about like you're
halfway through life and you've got this
and maybe you're 15 years into your
marriage it's not gonna connect for you
yeah but like when I [ __ ] make a
video for like hey kids you just
graduated and like you don't know what
the [ __ ] you want to do and your parents
pressure this and then the end that's
gonna work for twenty two-year-old I
think you didn't be doing more of that
from a writing standpoint what I would
call social like I think nothing's more
interesting than people's opinions it's
what we love hot takes and sports and
[ __ ] people watch cardi Beach the
biggest thing on the planet and that's
what God I mean she started just being
real on Instagram and people were like
oh this is not [ __ ] race man yeah
just being honest 100% right especially
in the times you know I don't you know I
paid enough attention to culture it
seemed you and this Josh dude you guys
had something like it like it was in the
news right like that's at some point
like a year ago weddings and so that's
like an interesting time to write the
truth your truth not like whatever the
back and forth was or like not the stuff
that you didn't feel comfortable maybe
just feelings I don't know I like
sharing feelings
you wrote a song about your feelings it
would be that's a good idea of course of
course it would cry especially if you
did it 100% based on truth not what you
think would play I will tell you the
single biggest reason I think I win and
I win bigger than where I am now
long-term is I never ever waver for my
truth I we have a sports agency now and
we represent my brother and I we
represent players ESPN asked me to do
this fluffy interview for their mobile
thing with one of my players four hours
before the NFL Draft for in Dallas our
player Josh Jackson was going in the
first round the whole time every mock
draft first round first round first
round
literally when we got the Dallas two
days before a draft we started talking
teams and there was like like I'll never
forget it one guy just said to us like
you know like you think you think he'll
go in the second round and we were like
whoa whoa what are you talking about
like he's gone first round and he was
like kind of alluding to like he might
slip out of the second round and I just
remember how it was going and I which I
didn't think he would ever go third
round but I definitely started putting a
pieces together the team started putting
these together AJ and the rest team was
feeding me back and like it now became a
realistic thing that he may slip out of
the first round so we sit down we're in
the couch and I'm supposed to interview
him and a couple other Kyle and one of
our other guys and a couple of my agents
were gonna hang out my first question
went right at Josh this is my own guy
and I was like hey man you know so for
three you know for last eight weeks
you've been told that you're gonna be a
first-round pick in the NFL Draft and
here we are hours before the NFL Draft
and there's a significant chance you may
slip out and you're about to go into a
green room with a bunch of guys and you
might be the last guy in there and you
might not get drafted are you ready for
that and it was funny I almost didn't
even understand what the [ __ ] I was like
I was almost a out of I was like what am
i doing like I'm like why am I like an
investigative reporter on my own guy
like I'm asking a question
other news outlets no either even other
news outlets are like yeah I'm not gonna
[ __ ] about the kid like it's just
because the truth is always gonna win I
did in the wine business when I started
that Wine Show I panned wines of friends
like friends like friends friends
friends people that like let me sleep on
their couch
when I went to Napa and Here I am at the
height of my popularity in 2012 hundreds
of thousands of people watching my show
me driving wine sales in America like my
moved because of what I said and I'm
like this wine moved both ways and I'm
like sitting there and I just knew that
I had to tell the truth it's like when I
go on The Breakfast Club it's really
tough to go on Breakfast Club when
you're a 42 year old white man and be
like nobody cares about your problems
that's dangerous territory that's I'm
not tone-deaf I just know it's the truth
and I just think the truth will help
like it will always win so back to that
song yes if you actually were 100%
authentic not 90 not do you know what I
mean you can't win you can't win when
you're leaving something on the field
anyway so I would think a lot about
culture from a writing standpoint think
about think about this something can
happen in culture whatever it is a
volcano Guatemala Roseanne Barr
something positive like a kid you know
oh I've never you know I don't I know
we're filming this but [ __ ] I'll say
it for the purpose audience you know I
don't like to go here some little girl
gave her shoes or something to another
girl remember about the thousand dollar
gift certificate the Zappos Amazon like
a couple weeks ago some little girl went
viral cuz she got a gift card and what
she did with it but I think on her
birthday or what it was just a great
story where she like did right by
somebody gave up like her shoes to
somebody else nice Center $1,000
you know Zappos gift cards so she guy
was like buy as many [ __ ] shoes as
you wanted right that's my I don't
really I didn't I don't talk a lot about
the stuff I do like that even this was a
little bit uncomfortable but I want the
audience to hear it because you could
have wrote a song about that yeah it
could have been like gifting shoes and
then you could have taken it it would
have just been in the zeitgeist you
might have made one little reference by
rhyming her name and she would have
thought that's the coolest but the
bigger thing was selflessness and how
doing the right thing is always the
right thing
I don't think enough pn you could have
it out the next day got it
the reason nobody used to write like
that is because the album came out nine
months later and that moment was gone or
even if it's a woman it cliffie you
don't even have to record the song you
just do alive or you can just [ __ ]
record the song yeah and if soundcloud
you're minor leagues and if spotify is
your major leagues you could play you
could I don't think people take enough
risks cuz they're precious with their
music I think no one song can kill you I
think one song can make you huge for us
your life and that's how my brain works
yeah and I think artists think one song
can kill them totally and I think
they're wrong well Lil Wayne put out
entire [ __ ] album or is it like
[ __ ] Jimi Hendrix yes nuke dogs sleep
lyin like everybody's put out a [ __ ]
song you make we make unlimited videos
it's suck [ __ ] especially Wendy rockin
it oh [ __ ] okay cool yeah okay yeah I
mean feel free to use this as like a
spring pad to a relationship and if I
can just hit me up cold like will help
so just tell me what matters
well definitely use some music in our
contact yes that's great yes some of you
touched makes contact court yeah yeah
that's also if there could just be an
opening line of dialogue that's it yes
that's always what I want are these
things to know everything that I hear
you say it's just like it's literally
because some of the stuff is like memory
lane three weeks ago that's why I was
saying yeah I get it
dude that's like you know your liver you
know if you live for Friday yeah our
biggest thing is I can't say there's
okay so we have to wait till Monday to
get an answer you know our weekend is
for or or literally the amount of people
today that are already like looking at
the weather on Saturday and Sunday
yeah like already looking at their
Friday afternoon which is great and
listen I you know what's funny I now do
it more than
ever because I'm I'm enjoying my
weekends with my family so much so I I
get it the bigger theme is if you hate
your Monday through Friday you're in big
trouble
your big [ __ ] trouble it's how do
people not understand that when you
eliminate sleeping it is what you do you
will be 2270 2259 you will spend your
prime of your life more than 50% of it
in a job I mean you better really cook
it and then people have jobs they hate
just to like maintain their lifestyles
which is completely usually based on
like other people's opinion and it just
there's so much broken there's so much
opportunity with the Joneses keeping up
with the Joneses I mean that would be
one of the first songs of my album
straight 100 percent in ceramic
amplifies it but it's fashioned to like
it's what we do it's how we express
ourselves keeping up with the Joneses
yeah
that would literally be one of my like I
would probably call it something keeping
up with the vaynerchuk's and like write
a song be like you [ __ ] like please
do not care like why do you know how
wrong everything is wrong when you care
about somebody else's like then like
people buy homes and neighborhoods they
can't afford cuz they're gonna think I
mean just well it's like you're saying
it's like who who utilizes their six
bedrooms I'm hot about our rooms right
yeah well you get in you get in the mill
awesome suite you so much enjoy your
enjoy New York of course guys real
[Music]
where